one of the most remarkable things about
the mathematician ramanujan
was that he was mostly self-taught today
i would like to show you the math book
that ramanujan read when he was 16
and it is said to have been one of the
key factors
in awakening his genius that book
is a synopsis of elementary results
in pure and applied mathematics by
g s carr now this book might
not have been the best choice but it's
what ramanujan could get his hands on
he was quite poor and a friend lent him
a library copy of this book the book was
a collection of around 5 000
mathematical theorems and ramanujan
studied it
in great detail the author was a
private tutor for students preparing for
exams such as the cambridge university
mathematical tripos
and the book was written to be kind of
an aid for these students
in preparing for the exam and it wasn't
really intended to be a stand-alone
teaching resource the author mentions
this in the preface of the book
saying that it is arranged with the view
of assisting the student
in the task of revision to this end i
have in many cases
merely indicated the salient points of a
demonstration
or merely referred to the theorems by
which the proposition is
proved he says that it should be a
similar pleasure
to a traveler who is discovering the
roads for themselves
with the assistance of a map the concise
nature of the book is quite important
because
it may have influenced ramanujan's own
approach to writing down mathematics
he was famous for not really giving any
proofs of his discoveries
and in the first letter that he wrote to
professor hardy
where he laid out pages and pages of his
mathematical discoveries
he didn't give any proofs of them or
indicate where they really came from
and in hardy's response to ramanujan he
said
you know these look promising but before
i can believe them i need to see your
proofs
and much of the collaboration and the
years that followed between
hardy and ramanujan was about hardy
teaching ramanujan
how to write these formal proofs such
that his work
could get published so maybe that was
the influence of the writing style in
this book
but it could have been some other
factors as well paper would have been
quite expensive for ramanujan
so maybe that's why he chose to only
write down his final results
and he did his working elsewhere he
might have also thought that it was
unnecessary to write down any proofs
because maybe to him
if someone asked him where an equation
came from
he could just see it in his mind
so let's have a look at some of the
pages of this book
and we'll have a look at how the author
describes things
the book is huge and it starts off with
some
basic algebra factors are the very first
thing that is mentioned
but then it accelerates through the
theory of equations
trigonometry geometry
conics it lays a foundation
for differential and integral calculus
and differential equations it also
covers some pretty advanced ideas that
even i don't understand
and there are some words here that i
don't think i've seen before
ramanujan published his first journal
paper when he was 24
and was published in the journal of the
indian mathematical society
and it was about properties of the
bernoulli numbers
now bernoulli numbers are defined in the
text
but there isn't any mention of their
properties
so perhaps this inspired ramanujan to
want to fill
in the blanks on page 359
we can see where ramanujan likely first
learned about the gamma function and the
gamma function
went on to feature a lot in ramanujan's
work
so much so that he mentioned it as one
of the results he was most proud of
in his first letter to hardy there's
also a mention
of things like infinite series and their
convergence or divergence
and that's another thing that i think
was really important to ramanujan's
thinking
and perhaps this is where he first got
inspired
so do i think that you should go and try
to read this book
well no i don't i don't think that there
is anything particularly special about
this book
and i think in the case of ramanujan
what was special
was the reader i think that the best
book to learn math from
is the one that you can get your hands
on whether it's
from the local library or from a
second-hand bookstore or
lent from a friend like in the case of
romanogen
then that's probably going to do you
just fine
as long as it's pitched at the level
that you're looking for
i think that this synopsis of
mathematics that we've spoken about
is probably a bit difficult for most
people
certainly not the easiest book to learn
math from
but in the description i have linked to
a free pdf of it
if you really do want to use it as your
resource or just have a little look at
it a bit more out of curiosity
if you do want some book recommendations
i've made videos
on books for learning mathematics and
books for learning physics
so i'll link them down in the
description along with a few other
resources
including the subreddit r learn math
now you can read about maths all you
want
but it will be doing practice problems
and exercises for yourself
that will really cement the ideas
another resource
is brilliant.org who have been a
supporter of my channel for a long time
and are the sponsor of this video if you
are looking
for an interactive resource where you
can learn
at your own pace then brilliant is a
great option
brilliant have over 60 courses in math
science and computer science
and you can sign up for free at
brilliant.org tibby's
and see if it's a good fit for you if it
is then by using my link you can get 20
off a premium membership so thanks
brilliant
and thanks to my patreons including
today's
patreon cat of the day holly
thanks for watching and i hope to see
you next time
you